there's now a state of emergency across
kazakhstan after four days of violent
protests
first over the cost of fuel
then over the leadership of president
kasim jomar takayev who has fired his
cabinet and named a new acting prime
minister takayev is urging demonstrators
to cool off
dear compatriots i urge you once again
to see reason and not to react to
provocations from inside and outside to
the euphoria of rallies and
permissiveness
calls to attack office spaces of
civilian and military authorities are
absolutely illegal this is the crime
followed by a punishment
kazakh citizens took to the streets on
sunday to denounce the government's
decision to raise the cost of liquefied
natural gas used in cars from 11 cents
per liter to 28 cents per liter in a
country where the monthly minimum wage
is less than a hundred dollars
demonstrators say they can't afford it
the protests have grown both in size and
in purpose namely a public call for
accountability
at the united nations an appeal for calm
following with um
concern and monitoring the situation uh
in kazakhstan
i think it's very important for all
involved
in these current events to exercise
restraint refrain from violence and
promote
dialogue in addressing all of the
pertinent issues
while at the white house push back
against a narrative being pushed by
russia there are some crazy
russian claims
about the u.s being behind this so let
me just use this opportunity to convey
that as absolutely false and clearly a
part of the standard russian
disinformation playbook we've seen a lot
of in past years
a former u.s diplomat calls the
political upheaval inevitable
but this has been festering for a long
time the stupendous corruption of the
nazarbayev family and nazarbayev corones
has caused a lot of concern in
kazakhstan where despite tremendous oil
wealth
income inequality is really quite
substantial and a lot of people are
living really close to the subsistence
margin
a public uproar over the cost of living
now challenging the powers that be in
kazakhstan
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington